for me personally being part of Call of
Duty and the biggest video game
franchise ever when the call came
through to come and do this it was a
no-brainer for me I'm personally a bit
of a space freak so for me this game
Call of Duty infinite warfare being set
in space is just just a brilliant step
for the game
you know what excited me about it was it
was a villain I don't get to play
villains very often you know I've never
played a villain before my take on
Admiral Koch is the e has an element of
the dictator by him he's an invading
commander he's someone who wants to
control a whole race of people and feels
that he's entitled to do that he's also
not afraid of death that makes him
incredibly terrifying
save the bullet but I think what was
great with with sailin Koch is that he's
a madman so I think that was that I
found that very fun to play like all
best villains psychotic and
unpredictable and I really enjoyed
playing psychotic and unpredictable it
was a really interesting challenge this
this felt quite theatrical to me it's
something I would definitely definitely
do again I found it
freeing and who's just a lot of fun